on continue avec françois vincent qui
est le vice président pour le québec à
la fédération canadienne de l'entreprise
indépendante bonsoir en ce moment c'est
fillon alors est ce que ce calendrier
si ce que vous attendiez
c'était une demande de la fédération
canadienne de l'entreprise indépendante
c'était une attente de deux pme sur
trois au québec quand on regarde au
canada la demande pour l'assouplissement
des mesures s'étaient 53% il était temps
monsieur fillion local prévisibilité et
ce pas un luxe pour un dirigeant
d'entreprise non c'est pas un luxe
effectivement la prévisibilité ça arrive
aussi trois semaines après le
gouvernement fort dans qui avait aussi
annoncé ces dates et qui culminait comme
le gouvernement legault aujourd'hui au
14 mars est ce que vous êtes d'avis
est-ce que vous est ce que vous êtes
d'accord en fait avec le fait que c'est
extrêmement complexe compte tenu du
système de santé au québec qu'on ne
pouvait pas donner de prévisibilité
avant aujourd'hui
mais la deuxième vague c'était complexe
pour le système de santé qui est un code
de couleurs et des entrepreneurs part et
j'en étais capable de savoir un peu plus
ce qu'est ce qui se passe et
comment après 22 mois de pandémie on
peut demander à on peut laisser des
entrepreneurs d'un n'ayant comme seul
dans une situation qui sont encore plus
fragiles on peut comprendre que le
système de santé c'est difficile au
québec mais d'ailleurs donné donne en
exclusivité la soixante dix huit pour
cent des pme au québec pense qu'on
devrait mettre un peu plus d'axens dans
le débat public sur le système de santé
vous avez fait une enquête donc fait des
sondages régulièrement la fci vous dites
que soixante dix huit pour cent sont
d'avis qu'on devrait parler davantage du
système de santé ouais la question
c'était nous pensons que l'état actuel
de notre système de santé devrait
prendre plus de place dans les dépôts
publics
quand on regarde son
hypothèque que
l'économie et quand on regarde le nombre
de lits disponibles par rapport aux
autres juridictions de l'occident on
peut peut-être se poser une question
comment on peut justement améliorer ça
peut pas tout faire mais l'économique
une demande sans limite est ce que vous
comprenez donc aujourd'hui dans le
propos de monsieur legault qui disent il
faut changer d'appproche pour les
prochaines vagues ou les prochains
variant si ça devait se produire est ce
que vous entendez par là qu'on ne va
plus refermée comme on vient de le faire
mais on espère sincèrement les
entrepreneurs font partie de la solution
veulent faire partie de la solution on
était capable de mettre des mesures en
place ont fait des investissements
majeurs pour protéger leurs clients
protéger leurs employés se protéger eux
mêmes ont été fermés y voit des secteurs
qui ouvre plus rapidement ou dans des
écoles par exemple que trentaine
d'élèves ou même dans des gymnases qui
est des centaines d'élèves qui mange qui
attendent que les restaurants ou ou des
bars qui vont attendre vingt jours avant
de réouvrir quand ci avait un permis
mapaq qui servirait de la nourriture
pour et ouvrez donc des incohérences
comme ça c'est les entrepreneurs qu'on
lis les commentaires des membres de son
âge là et il se soucie dont ils sont
capables de vivre avec la septaine
certitude là et beaucoup beaucoup de
commentaires de détresse psychologique
ou si l' on le sent dans la population
qui nous fatigue mais là on est des
entrepreneurs sont en train de perdre
possiblement la projet d'entreprise ou
de revivre l'enfer de retrouver de
personnel après avoir été capable de
renouveler la leur personnel avant après
la deuxième vague donc et donc on voit
jusqu'où dans l'aide d'un soutien
financier
maintenant qu'on a un calendrier puis
qu'on a des dates là vous vous attendez
à quoi sur le soutien financier de
l'état
et doit être maintenue on pense qu'il
devrait ajouter aussi aux entreprises
qui tombent entre les craques du système
je peux donner l'exemple à des
fournisseurs alimentaire qui nous ont
dit que ayons eu des pertes énormes avec
la fermeture des restaurants mais hilton
y avait pas d'être dirait des nettoyants
au centre-ville qui ont vu leur en faire
tomber kabyle télétravail quand les
rassemblements des fêtes ont été annulés
un adaptation aussi de led permettent
notamment sur la demande et souvent pour
que l'acte de québec et plusieurs mois
années pour rembourser le remboursement
du pacte et du pea upmc sur trois ans
l'équivalent des paiements hypothécaires
sont le fait sur 10 ou 15 ans on va
donner un peu de répit aux dirigeants
d'entreprises pour pouvoir rembourser
leurs prêts et remettre leur entreprise
à niveau un dernier mot sur le
télétravail qu'est ce que ça signifie
que l'annoncent de la fin du télétravail
obligatoires
une excellente nouvelle j'ai cosigné une
lettre ouverte avec la fédération des
chambres de commerce les manufactures
exportateurs du québec le conseil du
patronat du québec la chambre de
commerce du montréal métropolitain et
une demande de la mairesse de montréal
aussi les commerces du centre-ville sur
énormément du télétravail mais ce n'est
pas quelque chose qui se fait qu'ils se
faire rapidement il y avait beaucoup de
travail qui a été fait par les
gestionnaires d'entreprises pour créer
des modèles hybrides complètement été
arrêté avec le télétravail est
obligatoire donc c'est une bonne
nouvelle le prof pernette des
entreprises de ramener des employés au
bureau ce qui est important pour la
productivité un pauvre où la conception
aussi la créativité ok monsieur vincent
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci pour l'invitation
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit